on the show tonight Barack Obama
actually scolding Senator Tim Scott a
new chapter we have in the DeSantis
Gavin Newsom Feud we have that that tape
tonight Straight Ahead also Congressman
James Comer with an update on the latest
on the Biden uh Syndicate and the family
business dealings this is getting very
interesting the walls are beginning to
close in on Joe Biden we'll explain but
first is Biden in danger of losing the
first two primaries or the first caucus
and the first Primary in 2024. now while
he does hold a lead over the rest of the
democratic field the national surveys
now despite a tougher than expected
Challenge from Robert FK Jr he is
regularly now polling at 20 21 that's a
real number and Marianne uh Williamson
is is at 10 that's a lot of Democrats
that don't like Joe Biden new axios
report saying the president is in danger
of lose using both Iowa and New
Hampshire now this is self-inflicted
after his team indicated he might not
even appear on the ballot Biden wants
the first primary to be in South
Carolina obviously to me a middle finger
in the face of the first uh caucus State
Iowa the first primary state New
Hampshire back in February with the help
and the push from from Joe the DNC
capitulated agreed to boot you know Iowa
New Hampshire off the schedule to make a
room for South Carolina as the first
primary now remember in 2020 how
interesting Biden lost the Iowa caucus
and the New Hampshire primary both by
pretty healthy margins before securing
the endorsement very critical at the
time Jim Clyburn powerful South Carolina
Democrat and had a victory there and now
in typical Biden fashion he wants to
rewrite the rules for his own benefit
ironically he may have just cost himself
victories in two very key states in the
process opening the door for RFK Jr to
get serious momentum and giving growing
concerns over his age and stamina and
cognitive ability the the left may want
to start looking for other candidates
look at this according to a new axios
focus group this of North Carolina swing
voters who backed Biden in 2020 now
they're seeing his age is a serious
issue many saying that it may be too
late for Biden to ease their concerns
and of course with Joe's recent
struggles and endless gaffs can you
blame them now the two plus years Joe
has been in the White House have been
characterized by one bizarre moment
after another constant struggling
constant calves and during a dinner last
night well he didn't exactly ease
anybody's concern or worry his speech
was marked by the usual fights with the
teleprompter how do you fight with the
teleprompter his half finished sentences
and a rather ambitious infrastructure
plan that made absolutely positively
zero sense take a look you decide
it's already attracting billions of
dollars in private sector investment
even in districts even in districts that
in fact you wouldn't expect districts
that are all over the map
and then it's already attracting that
money where members are of Congress
voted against the bill we're still
having I made a commitment I said like I
said to all my folks in this in the all
the Americans in the State of the Union
Address I promise to be president for
all the people
so I'll see them on the at the
groundbreaking all these folks they
called it the G7 the bill back Biden
Bill back better and we realized that
got confusing so now we don't call it
that what we call it is here's the
bottom line look we're the ones that
caused the problem we have plans to
build a railroad from the Pacific all
the way across the Indian Ocean we have
plans to build in in Angola one of the
largest solar plants in the world I can
go on but I'm on I'm going off script
I'm going to get in trouble
I'm gonna get in trouble
by who who's going to get the president
Trump why did you always say I'm going
to get in trouble I'm going to get in
trouble what they're not going to give
me my ice cream and I'm going to get
yelled at and everything if I keep
talking off the script you got to be
kidding me all right so Joe you now if
you paid attention to that if you're
able to decipher that he's planning to
build a train let's get this straight
from the Pacific Ocean to the Indian
Ocean
across thousands
across thousands of miles of Open Water
Hey Joe we have something called an
airplane a jet for that anyway good luck
to Joe Biden anyway today Biden is being
ridiculed for his latest gaffe with the
DeSantis team one of his potential 2024
opponents mockingly calling it a bit
ambitious but unfortunately the
president struggles this week did not
end there he made this bold prediction
about the population of Africa not once
not twice but three solid times listen
to this prediction very closely
Africa
will have one billion people our
investments in Africa for example
there'll be a billion people in Africa
very shortly the global South they're
going to be a billion people in Africa
very shortly one billion
now Joey is very enthused about the
prospect of Africa's population uh
reaching 1 billion people we have one
one big problem according to the U.N and
their estimates the population of Africa
at the beginning of 2021 was almost 1.4
billion in fact Africa's population
topped 1 billion all the way back in
2009 when Joe became vice president a
day I'm sure he does not remember
so with Biden's endless struggles and
growing questions about his age stamina
and cognitive abilities why would he
deny himself the chance to pick up
delegates in Iowa New Hampshire and is
he now opening the door ever so slightly
for other Democrats to seek a new
candidate hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else